bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt francs 68 membres du
congrès américain demande donc à
l'administration byden de se tenir à
l'écart de l'organisation du référendum
constitutionnel prévu le 27 juin
prochain c'est un référendum contesté
dans la rue
de quelle manière les états unis sont
ils impliqués dans les intérêts haïtiens
avant avant de répondre à votre question
j'aimerais j'aimerais quand même
apporter quelques précisions
d'abord quand on parle d'haïti
le temps est toujours très pessimistes
il faut bien comprendre qu'il n'ya pas
de soucis polémique pour autant c'est
pas dans un souci polémique ni le
victimisation systématique d'haïti en
tout cas ma préoccupation à moi c'est
d'éclairer les événements vaut mieux
faire comprendre
haïti est aujourd'hui montré que dans le
cas d'haïti il n'y a ni fatalité ni
malédiction il ya des explications au
sujet des événements il ne survienne pas
par hasard
tout ce que vit haïti aujourd'hui vient
que depuis des décennies il n'y a pas
d'état en haïti les élites les
dirigeants politiques n'ont rien faire
ce sens pour construire un état
rien et les états unis comme vous disiez
la super puissance voisine
tout comme la france ancienne anciens
pays colonisateurs d'haïti n'ont pas
aidé en ce sens ce pays a des ressources
culturelles des ressources humaines et
n'en finit pas de sombrer dans le chaos
il est temps vraiment que les hommes les
femmes les enfants d'haïti et accès à
une vie décente
c'est important de le préciser parce que
quand on parle d'haïti on est toujours
dans des termes durs dans les termes
négatifs
alors aujourd'hui on se retrouve face à
une contradiction ou effectivement il ya
un gouvernement il ya un président qui
est du pays qui est président du pays
donc qui a un caractère national
c'est ici à haïtiano haïtien en même
temps le problème haïtien l'haïtien ne
se règle pas ils ne seraient que pas de
façon haïtiano haïtienne alors on dit
vous savez dans les manifestations fait
dire aux gens des choses à haïti on l'a
fait dire oui pas de pas de
pas d'ingérence étrangère pas
d'ingérence étrangère mais comment
va-t-on résoudre le problème avec les
gens en place
en tout cas alors justement suis à même
s'il a ni crédibilité ni légitimité
jacques les hollies et 1000 ça nous
amène à la question que je vous pose est
est-ce que concernant précisément les
états unis vous pensez qu'ils sont
impliqués ils ont dans les dents des
intérêts haïtiens les états unis depuis
les etats unis auraient occupé haïti de
1915 à 1934
depuis 1915 tout ce qui se passe en
haïti de politique est piloté par les
états unis tout au moins cautionné par
les états unis où les états unis comme
les yeux il n'y a aucun doute là dessus
donc la question la réponse est dans la
question
les états unis veille au grain très fort
sur haïti pour des raisons historiques
ce ne sont pas mes propos à moi c'est
l'histoire le montre
voilà donc bien sûr qu'ils sont
impliqués dans ce qui se passe mais les
états unis n'ont pas voulu s'en occuper
le président et le précédent président
est ce qu'il ya un centime aggraver les
choses parce qu'il ya un ressentiment
très fort a envers les états unis de la
part des coques le ressentiment il est
dans le fait est là par des haïtiens du
fait que les états unis n'agissent pas
tout au moins tolère ici ce qui se passe
maintenant lite x est ça la chose de
ressentiment faut pas se méprendre le
président actuel c'est genest le
gouvernement illégitime et illégitime
bien comprendre la situation en haïti le
président actuel c'est jovenna moïse et
se passe-t-il actuellement dans votre
pays pourquoi votre pays aujourd'hui et
plongée dans le chaos si on peut dire
les choses ainsi puisqu'il ya une forte
contestation
concernant le projet de réforme
constitutionnelle pour reprendre la
chose dès le début le président joël
moïse a été élu en 2016 et lila pas il
est apparu que son élection était
entaché d'irrégularités
donc les élections ont été annulées il a
été réélu si j'ose dire les riches de
nouvelles élections ont eu lieu
il a été réélu en 2017 or il est élu
pour cinq ans la question est les
haïtiens andy et compte tenu de la
situation
comme vous voyez les images que vous
voyez à côté de moi et que les choses
devaient changer c'est à dire que josé
ruiz élus en 2016 devaient partir en
sa réponse a été non qu'il était lui en
fait en 2017
il doit partir en 2022 et les américains
disent oui il doit partir en 2022
tout au moins se taisent en tout cas
disent que les élections ne peuvent
avoir lieu que fin 2021 voilà voilà d'où
vient tout ça et sans compter qu'ils
avec la corruption qui à l'insécurité
qui régnait vous avec les gens qui les
tient aujourd'hui même des français qui
sont enlevés
donc les états unis veulent le départ de
jovenna louise ils ne le veulent ils ne
veulent pas qu'il parte avant la fin de
son mandat qu'il considère être 2022
voila voila tout problème tout litige
viennent de là et donc on est dans une
cité dans une situation totalement
contradictoire in explique inextricable
même si les juristes haïtiens comme le
dit dans le courrier de votre les
court-courriers des 68 élus des
parlementaires américains ont adressé au
département d'état il est très clair
qu'il n'y a plus de légitimité plus de
crédibilité pour ce gouvernement est que
ma foi les états unis persistent à jouer
la différence bien sûr ils estiment
qu'ils ont d'autres problèmes à régler
ça j'ai envie de dire ça se comprend
mais je ne l'achète ou pas selon vous
les la demande des 68 membres du congrès
américain à l'administration maiden de
se tenir à l'écart de 2
de ce qui se passe actuellement dans
votre pays elle est légitime
je pense et je peux vous donner une
précision
les etats unis sont intervenus pour
déloger des dictatures en 1994 pendant
88 94
pourquoi parce qu'à l'époque il y avait
des boat people haïtiens c'est à dire
des gens qui montaient sur les bateaux
de fortune qui prenaient le large et qui
arrivait sur les côtes américaines
hélas les américains ont compris qu'ils
devaient s'impliquer
aujourd'hui je ne peux pas souhaité
qu'il se refasse une chose pareille mais
c'est une situation où les américains se
sentent menacés c'est ce qui manque pour
qu'ils arrivent après une des plus que
se décide aujourd'hui à intervenir à
faire quelque chose ils ne se sentent
pas concernés par le problème est dans
le même temps votre pays a besoin de
l'aide internationale
si haïti ne vit que de l'aide
internationale depuis 2010 qui a eu ce
fameux tremblement de terre le pays est
encore en reconstruction et la
reconstruction
on est à 10 % de reconstruction de ce
qui aurait dû être fait jusqu'à présent
le pays avec vie et puis comme on dit
pendant longtemps ce sont des ong puis
jusqu'à aujourd'hui mais ce sont des ong
qui a été les institutions sérieuses du
pays
quel pays peut fonctionner de cette
manière mais encore une fois je refuse
que l'on rejette la pierre
systématiquement sur le peuple haïtien
c'est trop facile
l'élite haïtienne à sa culpabilité les
la communauté internationale à ses
responsabilités dans la sphère ça c'est
clair
et elle parce que quand on entre temps
qu'on entretiendra la corruption tant
que la communauté internationale fermera
les yeux et toléra ce qui ce passe en
haïti et l'on pourra toujours dire on
fera vingt émissions pour dire la même
chose que le peuple haïtien croupit dans
la misère que la situation est
inextricable
comment voulez vous que des gangs reejer
un pays aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
possible il ya des milliers d'écoles les
c'est le l'enlèvement le kidnapping est
devenu une activité industrielle
commerciale qui n'enlève des gens pour
des petites sommes notamment
et maintenant il y avait religieux peu
est ce à ce que je me suis dit peut être
que ces religieux qui aiguise son
français enlevés qui de la perle a été
peut-être que ça fera réagir
l'international la commune merci donc ça
fait deux semaines il ya un lien merci
beaucoup à vous jacques léon et villages
rappelle dans l'association haïti
mémoires et cultures